So I think it's important for
each co-founder to interview each early
employee that walks through the door
in the first few months of the company.
You want everybody to be aligned
that this new hire is good,
not only for the business, but
for the company's culture.
There's no one way of testing for
the culture.
It's really a feel.
But I think there's very specific ways
to test on the professional side.
But on the cultural side,
it's making sure that that person
is aligned with what you do.
So asking them about their experiences
in previous places of work,
the work they've had,
what they liked and disliked.
What are they looking for
in terms of a job, right?
Those are the things that
you need to be ask for
and then I think overspending
time with that person is key.
Don't just make quick hires because you
need somebody to walk through the door,
you spend an hour,
looks good, let's get going.
Actually, spend more time
than you thought originally,
especially in the early
days of your startup.
Because you want to make sure that
person is right for the type of business
you're building, not just
professionally, but culturally as well.